é só maravilhoso é super interessante
está aqui brigado pelo convite só para
pegar um pulso da do pessoal que está
assistindo quem aqui sabe quem eu sou já
consumiu já consumir algum conteúdo meu
alguma vez na vida levanta a mão para
mim bem alto por favor show pouquinho a
gente então vou gastar dois minutos aqui
contextualizando nenhuma rapha avellar
sou seu daquelas mídia ela mente uma
gente publicidade super jovem a gente
tem um ano de vidro e a gente atende
melhores marcas do brasil e do mundo tem
cliente como tinder estão no espelho
investimentos por dentro de sacos sim
grandes marcas de verdade mas acho que é
muito mais interessante do que esse
cartão de visita é eventualmente um
pouquinho da história de como eu cheguei
aqui eu tenho 28 anos sou super novo e
eu tô no meu terceiro negócio de sucesso
e sem por cento deles construídos em
cima das coisas que os dois palestrantes
anteriores falar um
é que a internet tecnologia e sua
família então basicamente cortando a
minha história para uma versão curta eu
saio mercado financeiro super novo que
vai empresa família o piso estava super
mal das pernas a gente tava faltando
alguma coisa caixa de 3 milhões na época
tinha uma dívida quase do tamanho do
faturamento para quem conhece qualquer
coisa sobre o negócio sabe que uma
dívida desse tamanho no ambiente de
julho igual do brasil você não consegue
nem pagar o juros quanto mais que tal
principal da dívida e fato é que usando
tudo isso que tem instalado aqui
internet redes sociais e conteúdo eu
escalei esse negócio de 3 milhões de
faturamento esse ano a gente tá batendo
alguma coisa entre 110 e 120 milhões de
vendas então nas costas disso eu peguei
esse aqui que tava comigo que fez isso
comigo né tipo super enxuta seis sete
pessoas no time de marketing e comecei a
minha agência tem um ano e a fio sempre
um tô numa no evento começo eu tento
olhar para os rostos que estão lá na
audiência entendeu um pouquinho que
essas
e buscando aqui naquele dia eu acho que
eu tenho de conhecimento que
eventualmente pode agregar para vocês de
alguma forma que vocês possam sair daqui
de algum alguma coisa hoje eu não tenho
slide eu não tenho uma apresentação
muito rígida para seguir então encontrou
falando aqui eu vou desenrolar um pouco
do que eu acho que pode gerar valor para
vocês e olhando pra plateia é super
misturada a gente tem pessoas pouco
muito mais idade pessoas super jovens
estão começando a carreira eu acho que a
linha que eu gostaria decidir é dividido
em duas partes na frente num primeiro
momento eu queria dar um pouco de
contexto para todo mundo sobre a
oportunidade que existe aí fora porque
eu acho que muitos dos argumentos e das
teorias que a gente se apega são falsos
e eu queria tentar enquadrar isso e não
estou momento eu queria falar um pouco
de estratégias específicas de
eventualmente como qualquer um aqui pode
tentar fazer o que eu fiz ou pelo menos
se aproveitar do momento que a gente
vive hoje em dia então fala um pouquinho
de contextualização eu acredito de fato
com todo meu coração que a gente vive a
maior mudança sociocultural
e a gente sociais na internet e o
aparelho mobile eles mudaram forma com
que os negócios e as pessoas se conectam
transacionam esse relaciono de uma forma
nunca antes vista e dentro desse
contexto eu acredito que todo mundo
nessa sala e assim eu me incluo nisso tá
em quando eu ainda subi valoriza o
tamanho desse shift que a gente tá
vivendo eu acredito com toda minha
energia que todos nós somos ciborgues e
assim isso pode não ter se materializado
da forma que o filme with previram atrás
por um braço mecânico por uma cpu no
lugar do cérebro mas fato é que o
celular ele expandiu a nossa capacidade
analítica a nossa capacidade de
relacionamento a nossa habilidade de
influenciar pessoas negócios e qualquer
coisa de uma forma nunca antes vista e
dentro desse contexto eu acho que ainda
existe uma confusão tremenda e às vezes
até narrativas que eu respeito
é mais do meu ponto de vista discordo
que tendem a pintar esse cenário de
alguma forma um pouco menos otimistas do
que eu vejo então por várias vezes eu
vejo pessoas super amargas que seus
filhos estão por jogando o computador
durante 6 horas por dia que um casal sai
para jantar e fica mexendo no celular ou
então que amigos se reúnem e você olha e
todo mundo tá mexendo no celular e eu
não acho isso fundamentalmente ruim isso
é diferente
oi e aí que eu acho que um muita gente
se confunde porque os seres humanos eles
odeiam mudança que em verdade sei que
levantasse a mão bem alto quem é que
gosta de mudança perguntei mentir você
gosta das mudanças que te favorecem acho
que não te favorecem você chama de
problema e é verdade e dentro dessa
narrativa é a forma que as pessoas
enxergam sou chão digital ea internet
pinta a maneira com que elas vão usar
essas ferramentas para frente então eu
senão eterno otimista de tecnologia de
inovação e o olho para isso com um olhar
extremamente otimista e por isso eu sou
capaz de fazer vários das coisas que eu
fiz ao longo dos últimos anos então eu
queria tentar enquadrar vocês aqui
acreditar que a gente vive a maior
oportunidade de todos os tempos para se
fazer negócios para ser feliz para
construir a vida que faz sentido para
você
ah e tudo depende da gente porque não
existem mais intermediário hoje em dia
literalmente se você ama moda ou se você
ama ciúmes cara você tem o seu celular
você produz conteúdo com ele você se
conecta com pessoas você pode
literalmente começar um negócio do dia
para noite e escalar uma vida feliz a
partir dele não existem mais
intermediário não existe ninguém te
impedindo então dentro deste contexto é
que eu gostaria de dividir um pouquinho
e mais uma vez eu não tenho a pretensão
de mudar a cabeça de 100 porcento essas
pessoas o que o meu objetivo é que
eventualmente uma pessoa aqui
e sai daqui com uma visão um pouquinho
diferente e por isso tem a resultado
diferentes possa viver uma vida mais
feliz e construir a vida que sempre quis
tão tendo contextualizado um pouquinho
que o que eu acho que é um momento
sociocultural que a gente vive eu vou
tentar entrar aqui em estratégias
táticas um pouco mais específicos que eu
acho que todo mundo pode se aproveitar
isso é uma coisa que uma das coisas que
eu mais me orgulho como ser humano de
verdade porque eu não sou um palestrante
profissional eu não sou um guru de
marketing que vende um curso eu sou o
seu de uma empresa que tem em um ano sem
funcionários de escritórios em três
cidades no rio de janeiro e dentro desse
contexto com o executivo eu ainda assim
não perdi o pulso do dia a dia então eu
diria até que dentro da minha gente eu
sou uma das pessoas que é mais hard user
de social media de conteúdo dentro da
agência então o que tu queria trazer
para vocês não foi morto esse é o meu
modelo de como eu enxergo esse momento
que a gente vive e por consequência como
todo mundo aqui pode fazer uso disso
e ir ele passa por três coisas a
primeira entender o consumidor e atenção
segunda parte entendeu um pouquinho
sobre conteúdo e como é que isso
funciona e a terceira parte é entender
como é que você distribuiu isso podemos
se conectar com pessoas em escala e
falando de atenção eu acho que atenção é
o tópico mais importante dentro da
disciplina de marketing comunicação e
que é menos falado porque no fim do dia
se você quer me contar uma história se
você quer se conectar com uma pessoa o
primeiro passo é você ter atenção dela
seria sem minutinhos eu tava fazendo
esse discurso aqui se essa pateta
tivesse zero pessoas então e atenção é
mais importante ainda do que eu coloquei
aqui porque ele te dá uma metodologia de
enxergar para frente se eu entrasse aqui
começar a ser das estratégias
específicas sem contextualizar isso
todos vocês vão sair com o mapa sobre o
que vocês podem fazer esse ano no
próximo ano quem sabe nos próximos três
anos
é mas em algum momento o mundo muda e se
você não entende as engrenagens por trás
você é incapaz de reagir e o motivo de
atenção é super importante é porque tudo
que a gente faz hoje em dia sempre foi
pautada pautada no comportamento do
consumidor então lá atrás década de 80
quando surgiu por exemplo e-mail
marketing o motivo que surgiu o e-mail
marketing é porque as pessoas estão
começando a usar e-mail então fazia
sentido para as marcas e pelas empresas
estarem ali dentro na década de 90 anos
2000 com sorte banners e mídia
programática o motivo que surgiu é
porque teve uma explosão de navegação na
web então fazia sentido para as marcas
estarem amigos e para as empresas serem
encontradas nos recadinhos de buscas em
2019 a gente respira
é através desse cara aqui então chuta
onde as marcas e as pessoas precisam dar
ah então é por isso que atenção é
importante assim eu não me importo com o
chow-chow milho eu não me importo com as
plataformas facebook linkedin youtube
instagram seja ela qual for daqui a dez
anos vai existir algum outro veículo que
vai ter atenção das pessoas e se você
quiser construir resultados relevantes
você vai ter que saber operar aquele
ecossistema e aqui dentro dentro do
mobile o sistema operacional do celular
são as plataformas digitais então são os
spotify da vida os brinquedinhos da vida
os youtube seus twitters os tweets o
snapchat os ticket essas esses são os
sistemas operacionais na internet e a
curioso que cada um deles tem uma
dinâmica de comportamento de consumidor
totalmente diferente quando você puxa o
seu celular é abre no instagram você tá
no modelo mental de consumo de conteúdo
específico quando você abre o ímpio seu
modelo mental de consumo de informação é
outro quando você puxa o spotify para
ouvir um podcast ou para escutar música
o seu modelo mental é outro e se você
diz respeito
oi como é que você faz as suas
estratégias de comunicação você não tem
a menor chance a menor chance de ser
relevante ali dentro
bom e ali dentro a moeda de troca para
você começar a jogar esse jogo é
conteúdo é assim conteúdo é uma
brasil né vamos ser sincero todo mundo
tá falando de produção de conteúdo mas
conteúdo nada mais é do que os quatro
formatos que sempre existiram visual
audivisual texto e áudio escrito de
corpo todo mundo sabe disso todo mundo
sabe você pode fazer um vídeo todo mundo
sabe você pode produzir um texto não
sabe você pode fazer uma foto e o usar
essa gente preditivo ela mas qual é a
foto que dá certo o quê que funciona e
aí que está o grande lance porque a
gente viveu 100 200 anos de comunicação
e publicidade onde as marcas comunicavam
que elas queriam e dentro dessas
plataformas é 100 porcento sobre o que o
consumidor quer ver então ninguém quer
ver a propaganda da sua geladeira por
999 90 as pessoas estão ali buscando
alguma utilidade própria ninguém quer
ver a
um consultório médico as pessoas estão
ali eventualmente pesquisando alguma
coisa para melhorar a saúde delas e na
hora que você inverte a sua lógica para
pensar com a cabeça do consumidor e não
com seu objetivo é egoísta de negócios
aqui você começa a ter uma chance ali
dentro então essas plataformas elas são
vendas via grande você consegue aumentar
a escala da sua empresa e do seu negócio
e eventualmente ganhar algum potencial
na hora que você para de querer falar o
que você quer dizer que você começa a
pensar com a cabeça do consumidor e
mostrar o quê que essas pessoas estão
gostando ali dentro só que produzir
conteúdo também não é suficiente o mundo
tá lotado de conteúdo inclusive eu
acredito fundamentalmente que o melhor
livro do mundo que foi escrito nunca foi
lido por ninguém aqui a música mais bem
composta com a melhor melodia com a
letra mais virada nunca foi ouvida por
ninguém porque simplesmente não ganhou
o suficiente então a terceira parte é pô
como é que você pega isso e mostra para
o máximo de pessoas possível e aí a
gente tem dois status
a primeira parte é quando você coloca
esse controle nós plataforma e elas
distribuem de maneira natural lá dentro
que é o que a gente chama de orgânico e
o orgânico qualquer pessoa que conhece
um pouquinho desse ecossistema sabe que
ele sempre decresce ao longo do tempo
então pô cansei de ver as marcas o
reclamando que o facebook sumiu qual que
é os orgânicos das publicações agora o
mesmo gosta ser feito em torno do
linkedin do instagram do youtube e isso
é uma condição que sempre vai acontecer
agora isso não significa que a gente tem
que ficar junto com as plataformas e
atualmente não achar soluções para isso
porque uma das maiores oportunidades de
negócio que existem hoje em dia é você
usar vídeo dentro dessas plataformas
compra de vídeo distribuição lá dentro
eu construí todos os meus três negócios
nas costas disso a empresa da família
que eu entrei assim que eu sair do
mercado financeiro ela tinha um
excelente produto mas ninguém conhecia e
foi vídeo e deu essa distribuição em
escala um negócio a minha segunda e
e eu abri quer uma ideia que não existia
no país
e eu fui lá coloquei mídia e contei essa
história e escalei a empresa nas costas
disso a minha agência ela não teria a
menor chance de tá onde ela tá se não
fosse pela mídia ea curioso porque essa
é uma oportunidade de treinar a minha
empresa que tem sem funcionário
13 escritórios investe mais em mídia
digital hoje em dia do que muita
multinacional com 50 mil funcionários
com escritório no mundo inteiro
oi e o curioso é que essas plataformas
são movidos por dinâmica de oferta e
demanda ou seja quanto mais gente
anunciando mais caro é a quanto menos
gente anunciou mais barato é e no brasil
essas plataformas elas são extremamente
subir e investidas a oportunidade é
tremenda e esse jogo não perdura durante
muito tempo porque a hora que a
coca-cola pegar 100 milhões de reais do
flamengo pela de milho e parar de fazer
outdoor e parar de fazer ativação e
começar a operar dentro das plataformas
esse jogo onde eu pago de 2 a 7 reais
para mostrar minha mensagem para mim o
pessoas passa a ser 700reais r$800
porque essas plataformas são movidos por
dinâmica de oferta e demanda
bom então eu aconselho todo mundo aqui a
olhar para essa oportunidade com muito
carinho e eventualmente se você decide
executar em cima disso de alguma forma
para a empresa que você trabalha para o
seu projeto pessoal porque quer que seja
e ainda assim não der certo tem algumas
armadilhas principais que eu vejo as
pessoas caindo todos os vídeos número um
se você vai lá vai fazer tudo o que eu
falei e nada vai acontecer o nome disso
é feedback no mercado o seu produto
provavelmente é uma merda
e o seu serviço para velmente não
resolve o problema de ninguém e o mundo
te disso então você tem uma chance de
mudar número dois se você for lá fizer
tudo isso e não tiver a grande
resultados
a chance são que você não sabe fazer
e se você me dá uma bola de futebol e
bota para jogar no grêmio e flamengo
ontem eu vou fazer nenhuma no jogo
não sou jogador de futebol então tem uma
curva de aprendizado isso não é as
pessoas têm uma visão muito deturpada de
rede social de conteúdo até a ficar essa
coisa de gente jovem bota um estagiário
para fazer isso aí assim a ser uma das
ciências mais complexas que existem
porque linda com comportamento do
consumidor e na hora que você subir
valoriza é isso você portanto subir e
investe-se não tem a menor chance que
ter os resultados mas agora
ah se eu pudesse fazer um pedido aqui
seria que cada um de vocês olhasse para
essa oportunidade com outros olhos
produzisse um vídeo a mais uma foto a
mais um texto mais bastasse 1:00 2:00 a
mais cedo cão do sobre essas plataformas
eventualmente como é que faz podem se
conectar com os seus propósitos de vida
porque eu sei que fez toda a diferença
para mim e eu sei que pode fazer para
vocês também obrigado a
e aí